there's a lot of conspiracy theories in
this um in this current climate i mean
throughout history but now especially
and some of the conspiracy theories
put
a lot of power in the hands of the
intelligence agencies like cia fsb
mossad
mi6
they're basically the conspiracy
theories go that they control
the powerful people in this world
and are able to thereby
manipulate those powerful people and
manipulate the populace
in order to deliver different kinds of
messages and so on given your experience
with this kind of tension between
competence and malevolence would you say
there's some truth to those conspiracy
theories
not one way
i think i think there is there's
collusion there's collaboration but
i would think that uh like for instance
uh
some folks in the cia and the fbi are
being used by the ones that are really
in power
power is money power is wealth
i know power is going to go the other it
can go both directions you can acquire
wealth first which leads you to power or
you can acquire power first yeah
power is also knowledge i understand and
and uh in a
in a position in the society in the
military or in intelligence but i i
don't think it's a straight one way that
all the intelligence agencies control
the powerful people in their country you
see what's happening russia i mean putin
dominates
his intelligence agencies right
well
uh
so the question is which way the
direction goes but you're saying that
there is um it's not one way flow of
power i would think so uh
and i also believe it exists but it's
not as prevalent as you know not every
conspiracy theory uh
pans out and most of them don't
they're just damn rumors but that
doesn't mean they don't exist i
guarantee you they this there's
collusion there's people getting
together
and not necessarily
uh preparing a specific action but more
sort of a a plan to go forward and
maintain the position or even you know
strengthen the position that they
already have
you